Bitte schön.
Okay, danke.
Ah, die bekannte Frau Doktorin, hallo.
Ja, hallo, guten Abend.
Guten Abend, wir kennen uns doch.
Ja.
Ähm, es ist...
Die haben wieder Dienst.
Entschuldigung.
Haben Sie heute wieder Dienst?
Ja, ich bin heute wieder Dienst.
Sie sind heute wieder hier.
Ja, leider Frau Doktorin, ich musste halt heute schon wieder kommen.
Tut mir leid. Sie sehen.
Ich habe auch einige Sorgen und Probleme.
Was für Sie uns?
Ach, Doktor, ich habe eigentlich mehrere Baustellen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich Ihnen jetzt alles genau sagen soll,
mit welchem ich anfangen soll.
Ähm, aber ich überlege gerade, was könnte man denn heute anbieten?
Ähm, ich glaube mein jetziges Problem,
das mir Sorgen bereitet,
ist eher mein rechte Bein.
Die rechte Bein.
Ja.
Was ist mit jedem rechten Bein passiert?
Ich habe seit einigen Tagen merke ich,
dass ich so kribbeln,
dass ich so einen Brennen habe.
Das strahlt manchmal von der Hüfte aus bis in den Fuß.
Und manchmal ist es eher unterhalb vom Knie.
Ist immer sehr unterschiedlich.
Und jetzt werden aber die Schmerzen immer mehr.
Ja, bevor ihr ihre Schmerzen notiert,
können wir wieder ihre Argime und Argime-Daten wiederholen.
Können Sie mir bitte Ihren Nachnamen sagen?
Meine Namen vergessen, Frau Doktor.
Das haben Sie doch alles notiert vor der letzten Woche.
Ich habe meinen Namen vergessen,
jetzt muss ich noch mal überlegen.
Also, mein Name ist Herr Friedrich.
Friedrich?
Heinemann.
Können Sie mir bitte sagen, wie alt Sie sind?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
63 Jahre alt.
Können Sie mir bitte wieder verraten,
wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ich bin circa 1 Meter 76.
76?
Und ich will circa 85 Kilo.
85 Kilo.
Ja, danke.
Wann sind Sie genergeboren?
Ich bin geboren am 10. Februar.
10. Februar.
1900.
56.
50.
Okay, danke.
Sie haben mir gesagt,
dass die Schmassen am rechten Bein haben.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmassen?
Ich merke es seit 2-3 Wochen.
Seit 2 Wochen.
Ja, es kommt immer wieder,
aber jetzt ist es fast anhaltend.
Ja.
Haben die Schmassen langsam oder plus nicht begonnen?
Die haben eher ein bisschen langsam angefangen.
Sind aber jetzt seit 2 Tagen sehr verstärkt.
Danke, Herr Vorsum.
Ja, genau.
Sind die Schmassen dauerhaft da?
Oder gehen Sie auch wieder?
Ja, wir kommen und gehen.
Ich kann es auch nicht genau zuordnen, was es ist.
Deswegen bin ich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Manchmal kommen Sie plötzlich.
Ich bekomme dann kalte Füße.
Das ganze Bein tut dann weh, ganz plötzlich.
Wenn ich dann ein bisschen warte oder meine Füße etwas bewege,
dann wird es wieder etwas besser.
Manchmal ist das so,
dass wenn ich arbeite, ich arbeite auf der Baustelle,
ich bin Handwerker,
dann zieht der Schmerz vom Rückenn,
von der Hüfte wie ein Strom von oben nach unten.
Das Bein ist manchmal warm, manchmal brennt das.
Haben Sie Kribbelgefühl?
Auch ja.
Hatten Sie früher ein bisschen Wörter?
Ja, vor 10 Jahren hatte ich mal einen Bandscheinvorfall.
Manchmal im Orthopäden.
Und meinte dieser Orthopäde,
dass es ein leichter Bandscheinvorfall ist.
Damals hatte ich Krankengymastik gemacht.
Es ist besser geworden.
Aber diesmal mache ich die gleichen Übungen,
aber es hilft nichts.
Ich nehme Schmerztabletten.
Sie haben probiert diese Übungen wieder zu machen.
Es hat aber nicht gehofft.
Nein, im Gegenteil, es wird sogar schlimmer.
Sie haben auch Schmerztablette angenommen?
Ja, bei mir hilft ein Überprofen wirken eigentlich sehr gut.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Meistens nehme ich die 600 Milligramm.
Wie viel Mal am Tag?
Also 2-3 Stück nehme ich schon.
Haben Sie etwas Verwässerung gebracht?
Oder hat nichts gehofft?
Ja, das wird natürlich schon ein bisschen besser.
Ganz weg gehen die Schmerzen nicht.
Können Sie mir bitte sagen,
wie stark Ihre Schmerzen sind auf einem Skalophone bis 10?
Also jetzt in den letzten Tagen,
zeitweise schon bis 6-7, würde ich sagen.
6-7.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser für diese Schmerzen, wissen Sie?
Wenn ich nicht sagen,
dann kommt es manchmal spontan von alleine.
Manchmal bin ich, wenn ich laufe und mich bewege.
Was mir jetzt zusätzlich auffällt,
seit einigen Tagen ist,
wenn ich noch mal laufe, 50 Metern,
bekomme ich Schmerzen auch in den Füßen und in den Waden.
50 Metern.
Strecke.
Genau, da muss ich kurz warten.
Dann lässt es nach und ich kann da wieder weitergehen.
Können Sie sagen,
dass diese Schmerzen belastungabhängig sind?
Beim Belastung ist es sicherlich mehr, das stimmt.
Haben Sie auch in der Nacht diese Schmerzen?
Zum Teil ja, beim Liegen ist es schlimmer,
aber es gibt auch Nächte, da lässt es etwas nach.
Aber ich muss immer wieder meine Position ändern.
Normalerweise liege ich gerne auf der rechten Seite,
aber ich muss dann immer wieder aufstehen,
ein bisschen laufen oder mich drehen.
Auf den Rücken legen.
Das ist immer sehr wichtig.
Oder müssen Sie wegen dieser Schmerzen aufwachen?
Einmal ja.
Zitralen die anderen Rücken?
Nein.
Es kommt eher so im von der Entenwirbelbereich,
vom Boden,
in das Bein denke ich.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt? Nein.
Nein, Unfall hat ich keinen.
Okay, gibt es in diesem Bereich eine Schwillung?
Oder Rotung?
In welchem Bereich?
Am Bein.
Hat es mir nicht aufgefallen? Nein.
Ich habe es nicht aufgefallen.
Ist es hier am Ober- oder Unter-Schrankl?
Die Schmerzen.
Es ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Manchmal ist es im Oberschenkelbereich.
Manchmal ist es, wenn ich laufe,
in Bereiche der Füße und der Unterschenker.
Ich würde gerne ein paar Fragen über Ihre allgemeine Gesundheit stellen.
Wenn ich finde eine
Können Sie durchschlafen oder haben Sie Probleme mit einschlafen?
Also im Wesentlichen geht es schon, kann ich relativ gut durchschlafen.
Wenn ich mal sehr viel gearbeitet habe, dann ist es manchmal schwierig,
aber eigentlich kann ich gut durchschlafen.
Ich glaube, Sie haben viele körperliche Belastung am Arbeitsplatz.
Ja, also manchmal ist es schon schwierig.
Ich bin der Handwerker, das weiß ich, arbeite oft in den Baustellen.
Und dann ist es manchmal hektisch oder es ist manchmal kalt.
Oder manchmal muss man auch mal so einen schweren Sack Zement mal tragen
oder man hat eine komische Haltung beim Reparieren oder Arbeiten.
Dann ist es manchmal heftig.
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie diese Schmerzen nach dem einen z.B. schwer gesagt halten?
Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, weil wenn ich arbeite, dann merke ich das nicht.
Aber ich versuche natürlich in letzter Zeit auch,
keine schweren Säcke oder keine schweren Sachen zu tragen.
Wie sieht es mit Ihrem Verdauungssystem?
Haben Sie Probleme mit Essen?
Nein, habe ich natürlich auch gut.
Apatit, meine Frau kocht auch sehr gut.
Von daher kann ich eigentlich relativ gut essen und trinken.
Sie haben kein Problem mit dem Stuhlgang beim Last-A-Lassen?
Nein, das klappt bisher ganz gut.
Okay.
Herr Heinemann, lades ja Konkretkrankungen?
Ja, ich hatte vor circa 10 Jahren mal einen Herzinfarkt.
Damals habe ich zwei Stands bekommen und nehme entsprechend auch Medikamente.
Ich bin regelmäßig auch beim Kandälogen in Behandlung.
Ich habe einen leichten Blutdruck, der ist aber gut behandelt.
Da habe ich bisher überhaupt keine Probleme.
Und der Cholesterin sei wohl hoch, hat er, mein Hausarzt hat es mal gesagt,
da nehme ich Medikamente, aber es ist wohl nicht gut eingestellt.
Ich muss jetzt nochmal kontrollieren lassen.
Sie waren erhöht an Ihrem Lektion?
Ja, bei der letzten Kontrolle waren die Cholesterinwerte erhöhter.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie gegen ihr Blutdruck?
Da habe ich die, wie heißt es nochmal?
Ich hatte früher Ramio Pri, das habe ich aber nicht so gut gefragt.
Da habe ich immer so Husten aufgehört.
Die haben sich geändert, die heißen jetzt, glaube ich, Candesata.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Ich glaube, das sind acht Milligramm, meine ich.
Ach, acht Milligramm.
Ja, sie haben das, das sind sie, das sind sie.
Was sind Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ach so, ja.
Ich hatte früher Simastatin, da haben Sie recht.
Da hat es den Haushalt wieder umgestellt,
weil ich so ein bisschen Muskelsperren hatte.
Ich nehme jetzt Rosu, Rosuva, Hexalo, das sehe ich nicht.
Rosuvastatin?
Ja, zehn Milligramm sind das, glaube ich.
Und ich nehme natürlich Aspirin.
Ja, Aspirin.
Nehmen Sie nur Aspirin, 100 Milligramm.
Andere Blutverdner nehmen Sie auch?
Nein, nur Aspirin.
Okay.
Sind die alle Medikamente, die Sie einnehmen?
Als regelmäßige Medikamente, ja.
Wie gesagt, manchmal habe ich auch Ibuprofen,
die zwingende Schmerzen in letzter Zeit.
Und dann bekomme ich zum Magenschmerzen.
Daher nehme ich auch etwas gegen den Magenschutz.
Magenschutzstabilität. Pantoprosper.
Ich glaube, so heißen die ja.
Okay.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Letzte Zeit heißt, also ich war im letzten Sommer,
war ich im Urlaub mit Türkei.
Aber ansonsten, nein, ich nein.
Okay.
Herr Heinemann, sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Ja.
Er achtet mein Haushalt sehr darauf.
Ich bin auch jetzt wegen Corona geboostert.
Mit meinen Impfungen.
Da ist alles komplett.
Sehr gut.
Ich bin jetzt genau ein paar Informationen über Ihre Gewohnheiten.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, seit 30 Jahren schon nicht mich.
Aber früher mal gern geraucht.
Aber, habt es dann aufgehört?
Seit 30 Jahren.
Okay.
Sie haben aber früher geraucht.
Wie lange haben Sie früher geraucht?
Also über 10 Jahre, glaube ich.
Wie viel Paket am Tag?
Auch das war viel.
Fast jeden Tag zwei Pakete, wenn ich Zigaretten geraucht habe.
Wir haben sehr gut geschafft.
Ja, auch sehr schnell.
Ich hatte halt viel Arbeit, viel Stress.
Ja, Sie haben nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ab und zu mal ja.
So ein Gläschen Wein am Abend.
Jeder Abend?
Also wenn ich ehrlich bin, ja.
Trinken Sie nur Wein?
Oder am Wochenende trinken Sie andere?
Also ich trinke überwiegend Rotwein.
Okay.
Herr Hahn, nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht per seine Routine Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Ja.
Also meine größte Droge ist Käse.
Aber an so anderen Drogen habe ich nicht.
Okay, kein Kontakt.
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie ewigzige Krankheiten,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja.
Würde ich jetzt nicht.
Nein, also meine Mutter war schon sehr alt.
Als ich war, warum ist,
ich glaube,
sie hat wahrscheinlich einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Aber ansonsten,
nee, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Das ist alles okay.
Okay.
Ihre Mutter ist an Schlaganfall gestorben,
wie alt war sie?
War für 85 Jahre alt.
85.
Und ihr Vater?
Mein Vater lebt noch.
Er lebt im Dorf.
Er lebt in der Stadt.
Er ist relativ rüstig.
Er ist fast 90.
Also dem geht es gut.
Ja.
Hat er auch Glück?
Sobald ich weiß,
ihm überhaupt keine Medikamente.
Also hat er einen kleinen Bauernhof.
Und er kommt alleine zurecht.
Sehr gut.
Haben Sie Glück, bist du?
Bitte?
Ich habe noch zwei Schwestern, ja.
Sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind gesund, ja.
Wobei,
die eine meinte,
ihre Zuckerwerte seien wohl etwas erhöht,
hat der Hausarzt gesagt.
Das soll sie jetzt beobachten.
Aber sonst hat sie eigentlich keine Medikamente,
soweit ich weiß.
Ich habe jetzt nicht so viel Kontakt zu meinen Schwestern.
Ich weiß nicht genau, aber...
Okay, ich verstehe.
Herr Heinemann, wie ist sie von mir in Stuttgart?
Ich bin frei.
Ich bin frei,
wir haben ein Leben zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben vier Kinder.
Vier Kinder.
Sehr gut.
Sind die alle gesund?
Ja, möglicherweise sind die bisher immer noch
alle ganz gesund, ja.
Und Sie sind Handwerker von Beruf?
Ja.
Seit wann sind Sie Handwerker?
Auch seit meiner Kindheit.
Also...
Ein Beruf von Vater übernommen.
Der hat mir das beigebracht.
Ich war zuerst Schreiner.
Und dann habe ich dann ein bisschen
ein elektrischer Beruf gemacht.
Und ich mache auch Wasserinstallation.
Also alles, was zu einem Baustelle gehört.
Ja, Sie haben nur zwei Jahre Saurante.
Ja, ja, aber...
soweit es geht,
möchte ich schon weiterarbeiten.
Sehr gut.
Ja, Herr Heinemann.
Haben Sie noch weitere Bescheiden?
Die begleiten?
An sich jetzt nicht, nein.
Das sind jetzt im Moment meine Hauptsäugen.
Gut, ich habe aber mal Rückmenschmerzen.
Und jetzt bin ich in der Polenzeit.
Merke ich, dass wieder mein allergisches Asthma kommt.
Da habe ich aber ein Spray,
das ist mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Was ist das Spray?
Was sind Sie denn Namen?
Auch das ist so ein kleines Spray mit zum blauen Deckel.
Ich glaube, das heißt, es ist irgendwie
sagenwachhexal oder so ähnlich.
Okay.
Und ansonsten
wäre ich froh, wenn man jetzt diese Schmerzen,
die ich jetzt habe, behandeln könnte.
Aber Sie sind ja eine gute Ärztin.
Ich weiß ja, dass ich bei Ihnen in guten Händen bin.
Ja, ich hoffe, wir können das zusammenlösen.
Noch ein Punkt, bitte.
Haben Sie allergien?
Also das sind Polenallergen, ja.
Außer diese allergien, hätten Sie gegen Medikamente
oder Ausgabe-Berechlichkeit?
Nein, nein.
Bis auch, dass ich dieses Ramio-Pril,
diese Blutdruck-Tablette, die habe ich nicht so gut vertragen,
aber ansonsten allergien.
Ich habe auch eine andere Art,
die ich in der Polen allergien,
sie haben auch ein
J glasses, so kann man die
andere maze so auch nicht so gut
vertragen.
Aber ansonsten allergien.
Auf andere Tabletten habe ich jetzt nicht viel.
Ja Herr Heinemann,
Wenn es hervorließ, werde ich auch eine Unterschallung mit Ihnen durchführen.
Dann werden wir besprechen, wieder über Ihre Bescheidung.
Wunderbar, vielen Dank. Dann freue ich mich und hoffe, dass wir bald eine Lösung finden.
Ja, ich hoffe auch.
Vielen Dank.
Dankeschön.
Sehr gut, Herr Doktor.
Das war jetzt ein bisschen bewusst kompliziert gemacht.
Es war schwierig.
Mehr.
Okay.
Wollen Sie gleich eine Übergabe machen?
Oder brauchen Sie noch das Einsragen?
Ich brauche ein, zwei Minuten.
Haben die Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der Zwischenzeit noch Fragen?
Keine Frage, alles gut.
Alles haben Sie gut verstanden.
Die Teilnahme heute Abend ist aber sehr gut.
Das freut mich.
26 Ärztinnen und Ärzte.
Liebe Host, haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ja, ich kann anfangen.
Okay, dann machen wir weiter.
Guten Tag, Herr Obas.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne diesen Patienten Ihnen vorstellen.
Ich würde gerne einen Patienten an Ihrem Rechtenbein vorstellen.
Natürlich bitte schön.
Was haben Sie denn da für ein Fall?
Danke schön.
Herr Frisig Heinemann ist ein 63-Jähriger Patient.
Da sie bei uns wegen Schmassen an Ihrem Rechtenbein vorgestellt hat.
Er hat seit zwei, drei Wochen diesen Schmerzen.
Der Patient hat berichtet, dass Schmassen kommen von den Hüften
und Schmassen bis in den Fuß.
Die Schmassen haben einen Schmassen-Hüftel.
Das ist ein Schmassen-Hüftel.
Der Patient hat berichtet, dass er Auslärm, Diästhesie und Parästhesie haben.
Und seine Schmassen sind belastet.
Aus dem hat der Patient erwähnt, dass er nach dem 50 Meter Strecke,
er nach dem 50 Meter Strecke,
seine Schmerzen verschlimmen sich.
Ja, wo sind da die Schmerzen? Auch am Bein oder am Fuß? An der Wade?
An der Wade.
Er hat seine Schmerzen auf der Skala mit 6 und 7 bewertet.
Der Patient hat mitgeteilt, dass er vor zehn Jahren Diskusprolapses hatte.
Damals hatte er Krankengymnastik gemacht und nach diesem Krankengymnastik Physiotherapie.
Er hat seine Schmerzen besser geworden.
Wo waren diese Prolaps?
Er hat nicht erwähnt und hat auch mitgefragt.
LBS.
Deswegen hat er dieses Mal auch diese Übung ausprobiert.
Aber er hat gesagt, dass sie nicht geholfen haben.
Der Patient hat auch zwei, drei Mal am Tag Ibuprofen angenommen.
Aber er hat berichtet, dass diese Einnahme auch ihm mitgeholfen hat.
Der Patient ist Handwerker vom Beruf.
Er hat auch eine andere Arbeit.
Ja, der Patient berichtet das er auf in der Nacht schmatt ist, aber sein Positionen zu verander, hat ihm ein bisschen Verbesserung gebracht.
Als Vorarl-Krankungen hat er vor zehn Jahren erlittenes Herzinfarkt und er hat zwei Ständen bekommen.
Der Patient hat außerdem arteriale Hypertonie und Hyperlipidemie.
Seine Hyperlipidemie ist nicht medikamentös eingestellt, seine Hyperlipidemie ist medikamentös eingestellt, aber schlecht eingestellt.
Seine Werte sind immer noch erhöht. Er nimmt gegen sein arterialer Hypertolukandeser 10 mg ein,
100 mg und 20 mg für Rosivastik.
Und Ibuprofenbeinbedarf, Ibuprofenpantopresortbeinbedarf.
Er ist in der Zeit in Deutschland in Türkei gewesen. Er ist gegen Corona dreimal geimpft.
In der Familie in Anamnes ist es erwähnt, dass sein Vater an Schlaganfall gestorben ist,
seine Mutter an Schlaganfall gestorben ist, sein Vater lebt noch und er hat keine kurze Krankheiten.
Er hat zwei Schwester, eine Schwester hat Diabetes mellitus, die andere ist gesund.
Herr Heinemann ist verheiratet und hat vier Kinder. Sie sind gesund.
Er ist ein Handwerker von Beruf.
Abgesehen von dieser Banschmärzung hat er außerhalb der Rückenschmärzung, aber diese können ja Berufsbeding sein.
Er hat allergisches Atmen und wenn er diese Asmatik beschwert, hat er einen Hexalsprich.
Ich spreche nicht.
Das ist das Salbutamol.
Keine Allergie bei den Patienten.
Was ist die Analyse für die Kollegen?
Anhand einer Analyse für die Patienten, ein Bankscheiben für Diskusprolapsus.
Diskusprolapsus für Diabetes am Bein.
Diabetes Parisie, die Hebdigechmerzung am Bein sprechen.
Er hat eine Lumboischalgie.
Diese Lumboischalgie könnte natürlich durch einen Wandscheibenvorfall bleiben.
Er hat aber auch gesagt, dass er Wadenschmerzen hat.
Das lasst uns außer Dank an PAVK denken.
Sehr gut.
Also gute Versatzdiagnose würde ich zustimmen.
Das war genau das, was ich auch geschickt hat.
Erste Diagnose ist eine Lumboischalgie.
Das ist das Symptom des Schmerzens.
Was machen Sie für eine Untersuchung?
Die Bestätigen, ob es ein Wandscheibenvorfall ist.
Was brauchen Sie, um ein Wandscheibenvorfall festzustellen?
Ich bin Anesthesistin.
Dann müssen Sie es wissen.
Wir machen ja auch Schmerztherapie.
Wer hilft der Frau Kollegin?
Welche Diagnostik brauchen wir, um einen Wandscheibenvorfall festzustellen?
Es ist eine Untersuchungsmethodie, die ich nicht an mich erinnern kann.
Welche Diagnostik muss ich machen?
Was brauche ich, um einen Wandscheibenvorfall festzustellen?
Jetzt kommt es um.
Was brauche ich?
Wir haben eine Bildgebung.
Natürlich ist es eine Enttäuschung.
Ich war wahrscheinlich zu einfach.
Ich versuche diese Untersuchung.
Man muss nicht immer komplizieren.
Sie können mit einem MRT.
Ein Wandscheibenvorfall sehen Sie richtig.
Wie stellen Sie eine PAV-Pafis?
Wir lassen die Charlotte be候hen, um die
Geografie der Beinarterie und dann sehen Sie das auch. Wahrscheinlich hat der Patient eine
PAVK, denn er hat ja schon eine vorbestehende KHK, eine coronare Herzerkrankung, weil er einen
Herzinfarkt hatte. Er hat ja erwähnt, dass sein Cholesterin schlecht eingestellt ist. Ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit schon groß, dass er jetzt auch eine PAVK hat, das zufällig mit seiner
LUMO-Ishalgie zusammenfällt. Also so eignet man gleichzeitig. Sehr gut, das war schön. Sie sind
nicht reingefallen. Ich wollte Sie ein bisschen austricksen. LUMO-Ishalgie plus PAVK. Die Kollegen
haben dann gute Hinweise gegeben. Man spricht von einer Claudio-Cazio Intermittence. Dann gibt es
die verschiedenen Stufen PAVK-Stadium 1, 2, 3 von Tee und so weiter. Das haben wir ja schon mal gemacht.
Da haben die Kollegen schon eine schöne Liste gehabt. Und ja, sehr gut. Letzte Frage. Was macht man,
wenn jetzt ein Gefäßverschluss oder eine hochgradige Stenose bei der PAVK
im Bereich der Arteria publitea oder Arteria femoralis festgestellt werden? Was kann man da machen, außer aspirin?
Aus aspirin heparin. Ja, okay. Ja, am Anfang heparin bolus 5000 Titan. Und ja, bis PTA-Werte ein Zweifach oder
ein Zweifach erhöht ist eine Infusion. Heperin Infusion müssen wir verabreichen.
Okay, aber ansonsten. Ja, PTA. Ja, PTA. Dann. Ein Stand, genau. Sehr gut. Wunderbar. Das war gut.
Und haben wir anderen Kollegen, wir haben immer schöne Tipps gegeben. Die Gruppe ist sehr gut.
Geben immer mit Fragen und anderen Sachen gute Hinweise. Haben die Kolleginnen noch und Kollegen
Fragen? Keine Fragen. Gut. Dann können wir heute dann da aufhören und